how can it be explained that such
monsters as Hitler or Stalin were moved
to tears by music clearly they must have
associated human emotion with something
in the music but at the same time they
failed or chose they fail to make a
connection between the ethical and the
aesthetical they saw music as a haven
outside of real life one that was
associated with pure enjoyment in other
words the beauty of music which I've
already described as a physical
expression of the human spirit was
relegated to a remote area of the
dictatorial brain where it was not
permitted to make contact with other
areas of the intellect which might have
directly influenced thought and behavior
whatever it was in the music that moved
them was not allowed to seek its
equivalent in human life and action this
anomaly which is particularly ironic in
light of the inhuman brutality of these
two men's deeds may simba nala in the
context of ordinary people's lives
nevertheless the chasm between ethics
and aesthetics or to take a more
concrete example between the
understanding of life and then the
sending of music has dire consequences
for a society that suffers more every
day from the alienating effects of
specialization there is no end to what
music and teachers if we are able and
willing to delve into it and not
segregated from our intellectual lives
music has been banished over the years
to a remote kingdom of pleasure and
escape assumed to have nothing to say to
the parts of our brains that determine
every day thought or life
oh this is a sad state of affairs for
all involved music has the capacity to
express what humanity can do when it
overcomes its limitations music
possesses the power of communication
between human beings regardless of their
gender race or nationality all this may
be because music puts us on a path from
chaos to order it is a path that starts
from an idea even a disordered one and
proceeds to the development and
completion of a work that is supported
and sustained by its own logic if I can
understand the creative process that
leads to a finished work and I'm able to
retrace the steps from this organized
material to concise statement then I
might be in a position to truly recreate
the music in performance from the
opposing starting point namely by
started from the completed work and
going through a process of
deconstruction and analysis in order to
arrive at the distilled original idea if
in addition I can draw parallels between
this process and everything in life that
interests or touches me then I may have
understood the very nature of music